clever founder schedules the Friday
before the next week's board meeting we
just puts catch-up call 15 minutes sends
me a link sends me three times this
founder is very Savvy just says Hey
couple of things I want to get your
feedback on J Cal before the board
meeting now I know this is not to get my
feedback my feedback is going to come
during the board meeting this is to pre-
socialize some issues but this is the
ultimate and savviness I agree it's very
Savvy for for two reasons first of all
they're getting your brain working on it
a week ahead of time so that you can
actually be thoughtful during the board
meeting and second of all they're
building credibility and letting you
know that they're going to come to you
when there's a problem which is really
as an investor that's the kind of people
you want to invest in because you're
again you're there in this asset class
to actually build the company help
people gu guide them through their
Journey so I actually think that's a
real positive and your description of
Savvy is right on